there's friction at the meadow's care
owner ian somaru can't understand why
carers are refusing to have what he sees
as a miracle vaccine he's got
22 residents and all but one have had
the kovid jab
but of his 24 staff half have turned it
down
they're being quite selfish because they
don't understand that they're putting
people's lives at risk they come in here
on the understanding that they care for
the elderly
and they have a passion to look after
them and i would bring that into
question
so why are you still employing them i
made it
mandatory and compulsory on the terms of
conditions of employment
but i only did this for newcomers
who are coming in here i can't do it for
the
ones who were employed before
coronavirus came on the scene
94 year old resident irini clark
couldn't wait to get her vaccine
and is furious with some of the staff
not
all the staff has been done yet and i
thought they had but i found out they
haven't
and they putting us all at risk so do
you feel angry
yes very angry that they can be
so relaxed about it
and it isn't a relaxed virus it's a
deadly virus
these are some of the reasons staff gave
for not having the vaccine
there's no evidence to substantiate any
of their claims
this virus doesn't exist it's
scare-mongering from the government
i'm a 37-year-old who plans to have
children and i'm not going to jeopardize
my chances
i believe it's meant to restrict my
freedom as an individual there is not
enough data to prove its safety
one member of staff who has had the
vaccine told us
others were waiting to see how she
reacted to it
if they want to take the vaccine they
can but i think someone is trying to you
know see
how does it react and they are watching
us but there's growing concern what's
happening inside this west london care
home
is being reflected nationally it isn't
a major hurdle for us to get over this
because we know
that vaccination is is a key that will
assist us
to mitigate the risks out there for our
service users
and for our staff nearly 40 percent of
care homes haven't yet received the
vaccine
what we don't yet know is whether it
effectively stops transmission of the
virus
if it does there will be even more
questions about who is allowed to work
amongst people
so vulnerable to the killer disease lisa
holland sky news west london